she was greatly loved
candles lit flowers placed we love you
and balloons released all for alicia
gibolina alicia lost her life on may 11
after police say this man 28 year old
samuel schmid went inside the dotties on
flamingo and jones and stole a woman's
purse alicia's husband miguel along with
all of her friends from years of working
the casinos and gaming parlors in vegas
came out to show their support i cry a
lot of nights because i know she won't
be back
to see us again you know but i still
have a right here i have it right here
in my heart and she'll always be my
friend many describing this as a
senseless and disturbing act with the
hope that dottie's gaming will change
the way they handle operations within
their parlors every one of these because
they pay out so much money should have
security and i just think that they need
to
reassess how they pay people out as for
justice for gibolina one of the
organizers of the vigil nora merlino is
thankful for local law enforcement for
finding the suspect she was my girl
and she made you rest in peace said i do
want to shout out to metro thank you for
doing such a fine job